This is lecture twelve.
OK.
We've reached twelve lectures.
And this one is more than
the others about applications
of linear algebra.
And I'll confess.
When I'm giving you examples
of the null space and the row
space, I create a little matrix.
You probably see that I
just invent that matrix
as I'm going.
And I feel a little
guilty about it,
because the truth is that real
linear algebra uses matrices
that come from somewhere.
They're not just, like, randomly
invented by the instructor.
They come from applications.
They have a definite structure.
And anybody who works with
them gets, uses that structure.
I'll just report,
like, this weekend
I was at an event with
chemistry professors.
OK, those guys are row
reducing matrices, and what
matrices are they working with?
Well, their little matrices tell
them how much of each element
goes into the --
or each molecule, how
many molecules of each
go into a reaction
and what comes out.
And by row reduction they
get a clearer picture
of a complicated reaction.
And this weekend I'm going to --
to a sort of birthday
party at Mathworks.
So Mathworks is out
Route 9 in Natick.
That's where Matlab is created.
It's a very, very
successful, software,
tremendously successful.
And the conference will be about
how linear algebra is used.
And so I feel
better today to talk
about what I think is
the most important model
in applied math.
And the discrete
version is a graph.
So can I draw a graph?
Write down the matrix
that's associated with it,
and that's a great
source of matrices.
You'll see.
So a graph is
just, so a graph --
to repeat -- has
nodes and edges.
OK.
And I'm going to write down
the graph, a graph, so I'm just
creating a small graph here.
As I mentioned last time,
we would be very interested
in the graph of all, websites.
Or the graph of all telephones.
I mean -- or the graph of
all people in the world.
Here let me take just,
maybe nodes one two three --
well, I better put in an --
I'll put in that edge and maybe
an edge to, to a node four,
and another edge to node four.
How's that?
So there's a graph
with four nodes.
So n will be four in my --
n equal four nodes.
And the matrix will have
m equal the number --
there'll be a row
for every edge,
so I've got one two
three four five edges.
So that will be
the number of rows.
And I have to to write down
the matrix that I want to,
I want to study, I need to
give a direction to every edge,
so I know a plus and
a minus direction.
So I'll just do
that with an arrow.
Say from one to two, one
to three, two to three,
one to four, three to four.
That just tells me, if I have
current flowing on these edges
then I know whether it's
-- to count it as positive
or negative according as whether
it's with the arrow or against
the arrow.
But I just drew those
arrows arbitrarily.
OK.
Because I -- my example is going
to come -- the example I'll --
the words that I will use
will be words like potential,
potential difference, currents.
In other words, I'm
thinking of an electrical
network.
But that's just one possibility.
My applied math class
builds on this example.
It could be a hydraulic
network, so we could be doing,
flow of water, flow of oil.
Other examples, this
could be a structure.
Like the -- a design
for a bridge or a design
for a Buckminster Fuller dome.
Or many other
possibilities, so many.
So l- but let's take
potentials and currents
as, as a basic
example, and let me
create the matrix that tells
you exactly what the graph tells
you.
That's --, that's it.
So now I'll call it the
incidence matrix, incidence
matrix.
So let me write it
down, and you'll see,
OK.
what its properties are.
So every row
corresponds to an edge.
I have five rows
from five edges,
and let me write down again
what this graph looks like.
OK, the first edge, edge one,
goes from node one to two.
So I'm going to put in a minus
one and a plus one in th- this
corresponds to node
one two three and four,
That's a basis for the null
space. the four columns.
The five rows correspond -- the
first row corresponds to edge
one.
Edge one leaves node one and
goes into node two, and that --
and it doesn't touch
three and four.
Edge two, edge two goes -- oh,
I haven't numbered these edges.
I just figured that was probably
edge one, but I didn't say so.
Let me take that to be edge one.
Let me take this to be edge two.
Let me take this
to be edge three.
This is edge four.
Ho, I'm discovering
-- no, wait a minute.
Did I number that twice?
Here's edge four.
And here's edge five.
All right.
OK?
So, so edge one, as I said,
goes from node one to two.
Edge two goes from two to
three, node two to three, so
minus one and one in the
second and third columns.
Edge three goes
from one to three.
I'm, I'm tempted to stop for a
moment with those three edges.
The null space is actually one
dimensional, and it's the line
Edges one two three,
those form what would we,
A basis for the
null space will be
just that.1 what do you call
the, the little, the little,
the subgraph formed by
edges one, two, and three?
That's a loop.
And the number of loops and
the position of the loops
will be crucial.
OK.
Actually, here's a
interesting point about loops.
If I look at those
rows, corresponding
to edges one two three,
and these guys made a loop.
You want to tell me --
if I just looked at
that much of the matrix
it would be natural
for me to ask,
are those rows independent?
Are the rows independent?
And can you tell from looking
at that if they are or are not
independent?
Do you see a, a relation
between those three rows?
Yes.
If I add that row to
that row, I get this row.
So, so that's like a hint
here that loops correspond
to dependent, linearly
dependent column --
linearly dependent give me
a basis for the null space.
rows.
OK, let me complete
the incidence matrix.
Number four, edge four is going
from node one to node four.
And the fifth edge is going
from node three to node four.
OK.
There's my matrix.
It came from the five
edges and the four nodes.
And if I had a big graph,
I'd have a big matrix.
And what questions do
I ask about matrices?
Can I ask --
here's the review now.
There's a matrix that comes
from somewhere. of all vectors
through that one.
If, if it was a big graph,
it would be a large matrix,
but a lot of zeros, right?
Because every row only
has two non-zeros.
So the number of -- it's
a very sparse matrix.
The number of non-zeros
is exactly two times
five, it's two m.
Every row only
has two non-zeros.
And that's with a
lot of structure.
And -- that was the point
I wanted to begin with,
that graphs, that real
graphs from real --
real matrices from genuine
problems have structure.
OK.
We can ask, and because of
the structure, we can answer,
If it -- yeah, let me
ask you just always,
the, the main questions
about matrices.
So first question, what
about the null space?
So what I asking if I ask you
for the null space of that
matrix?
I'm asking you if I'm looking
at the columns of the matrix,
four columns, and I'm asking
you, So there's a basis for it,
and here is the whole null
are those columns independent?
If the columns are independent,
then what's in the null space?
Only the zero vector, right?
The null space contains --
tells us what combinations
of the columns -- it tells us
how to combine columns to get
zero.
Can -- and is there anything in
the null space of this matrix
other than just the zero vector?
In other words, are
those four columns
independent or dependent?
What else is in the null space?
OK.
That's our question.
Let me, I don't know
if you see the answer.
Whether there's -- so let's see.
I guess we could do it properly.
space.
We could solve Ax=0.
So let me solve Ax=0
to find the null space.
OK.
What's Ax?
Can I put x in here
in, in little letters?
x1, x2, x3, x4, that's
-- it's got four columns.
Ax now is that matrix times x.
And what do I get for Ax?
If the camera can keep that
matrix multiplication there,
I'll put the answer here.
Ax equal -- what's the
first component of Ax?
Can you take that first row,
minus one one zero zero,
and multiply by the x, and
of course you get x2-x1.
space.
The second row, I get x3-x2.
From the third row, I get x3-x1.
Any multiple of one one one
one, it's the whole line in four
From the fourth
row, I get x4-x1.
And from the fifth
row, I get x4-x3.
And I want to know
when is the thing zero.
This is my equation, Ax=0.
Notice what that
matrix A is doing,
what we've created a
matrix that computes
the differences across
every edge, the differences
in potential. differences are
zero, and that x is in the null
Let me even begin to
give this interpretation.
I'm going to think of this
vector x, which is x1 x2 x3 x4,
as the potentials at the nodes.
So I'm introducing a word,
potentials at the nodes.
And now if I multiply
by A, I get these --
I get these five components,
x2-x1, et cetera.
And what are they?
They're potential differences.
That's what A computes.
If I have potentials at the
nodes and I multiply by A,
it gives me the potential
differences, the differences
in potential, across the edges.
OK.
When are those
differences all zero?
So I'm looking for
the null space.
Of course, if all the (x)s
are zero then I get zero.
That, that just tells me,
of course, the zero vector
is in the null space.
But w- there's more
in the null space.
Those columns are -- of
A are dependent, right --
because I can find
solutions to that equation.
dimensional space.
Tell me -- the null space.
Tell me one vector in the
null space, so tell me an x,
it's got four components,
and it makes that thing zero.
So what's a good x to do that?
One one one one,
constant potential.
If the potentials are constant,
then all the potential
Do you see that
that's the null space?
So the, so the dimension of
the null space of A is one.
And there's a basis
for it, and there's
everything that's in it.
Good.
And what does that
mean physically?
I mean, what does that
mean in the application?
That guy in the null space.
It means that the
potentials can only
be determined up to a constant.
Potential differences are
what make current flow.
That's what makes things happen.
It's these potential
differences that
will make something move
in the, in our network,
between x2- between
node two and node one.
Nothing will move if all
potentials are the same.
If all potentials are c, c, c,
and c, then nothing will move.
So we're, we have
this one parameter,
this arbitrary constant
that raises or drops
all the potentials.
It's like ranking
football teams, whatever.
We have a, there's a,
there's a constant --
or looking at
temperatures, you know,
there's a flow of heat from
higher temperature to lower
temperature.
If temperatures are
equal there's no flow,
and therefore we can measure --
we can measure temperatures
by, Celsius or we
can start at absolute zero.
And that arbitrary -- it's the
same arbitrary constant that,
that was there in calculus.
In calculus, right,
when you took
the integral, the indefinite
integral, there was a plus c,
and you had to set a starting
point to know what that c was.
So here what often happens is
we fix one of the potentials,
like the last one.
So a typical thing would
be to ground that node.
To set its potential at zero.
And if we do that, if
we fix that potential
so it's not unknown anymore,
then that column disappears
and we have three columns,
and those three columns
are independent.
So I'll leave the
column in there,
but we'll remember
that grounding a node
is the way to get it out.
And grounding a node is the
way to -- setting a node --
setting a potential to zero
tells us the, the base for all
potentials.
Then we can compute the others.
But what's the -- now
I've talked enough to ask
OK. what the rank
of the matrix is?
What's the rank then?
The rank of the matrix.
So we have a five
by four matrix.
We've located its null
space, one dimensional.
How many independent
columns do we have?
What's the rank?
It's three.
And the first three columns,
or actually any three columns,
will be independent.
Any three potentials are
independent, good variables.
The fourth potential
is not, we need to set,
and typically we
ground that node.
OK.
Rank is three.
Rank equals three.
OK.
Let's see, do I want to ask
you about the column space?
The column space is all
combinations of those columns.
I could say more
about it and I will.
Let me go to the null
space of A transpose,
because the equation A
transpose y equals zero
is probably the most
fundamental equation
of applied mathematics.
All right, let's
talk about that.
That deserves our attention.
A transpose y equals zero.
Let's -- let me put it on here.
So A transpose y equals zero.
OK.
So now I'm finding the
null space of A transpose.
Oh, and if I ask
you its dimension,
you could tell me what it is.
What's the dimension of the
null space of A transpose?
We now know enough to
answer that question.
What's the general formula for
the dimension of the null space
of A transpose?
A transpose, let me even
write out A transpose.
This A transpose will
be n by m, right?
In this case, it'll
be four by five.
n by m.
Those columns will become rows.
Minus one zero minus one minus
one zero is now the first row.
The second row of the matrix,
one minus one and three zeros.
The third column now becomes
the third row, zero one one
zero minus one.
And the fourth column
becomes the fourth row.
OK, good.
There's A transpose.
That multiplies y,
y1 y2 y3 y4 and y5.
OK.
Now you've had time to
think about this question.
What's the dimension of the
null space, if I set all those
-- wow.
Usually -- sometime
during this semester,
I'll drop one of these
erasers behind there.
That's a great moment.
There's no recovery.
There's -- centuries of
erasers are back there.
OK.
OK, what's the dimension
of the null space?
Give me the general
formula first
in terms of r and m and n.
This is like crucial, you --
we struggled to, to decide
what dimension meant,
and then we figured out
what it equaled for an m
by n matrix of rank r, and
the answer was m-r, right?
There are m=5 components,
m=5 columns of A transpose.
And r of those columns
are pivot columns,
because it'll have r pivots.
It has rank r.
And m-r are the free
ones now for A transpose,
so that's five minus
three, so that's two.
And I would like to
find this null space.
I know its dimension.
Now I want to find
out a basis for it.
And I want to understand
what this equation is.
So let me say what A transpose
y actually represents, why I'm
interested in that equation.
I'll put it down with those
old erasers and continue this.
Here's the great picture
of applied mathematics.
So let me complete that.
There's a matrix
that I'll call C
that connects potential
differences to currents.
So I'll call these -- these
are currents on the edges,
y1 y2 y3 y4 and y5.
Those are currents on the edges.
And this relation between
current and potential
difference is Ohm's Law.
This here is Ohm's Law.
Ohm's Law says that
the current on an edge
is some number times
the potential drop.
That's -- and that number is
the conductance of the edge,
one over the resistance.
This is the old current
is, is, the relation
of current, resistance,
and change in potential.
So it's a change in potential
that makes some current happen,
and it's Ohm's Law that says
how much current happens.
OK.
And then the final
step of this framework
is the equation A
transpose y equals zero.
And that's -- what
is that saying?
It has a famous name.
It's Kirchoff's Current Law,
KCL, Kirchoff's Current Law,
A transpose y equals zero.
So that when I'm solving, and
when I go back up with this
blackboard and solve A
transpose y equals zero,
it's this pattern of --
that I want you to see.
That we had rectangular
matrices, but --
and real applications, but in
those real applications comes A
and A transpose.
So our four subspaces are
exactly the right things
to know about.
All right.
Let's know about that
null space of A transpose.
Wait a minute, where'd it go?
There it is.
OK.
Null space of A transpose.
We know what its
dimension should be.
Let's find out -- tell
me a vector in it.
Tell me -- now, so
what I asking you?
I'm asking you for
five currents that
satisfy Kirchoff's Current Law.
So we better understand
what that law says.
That, that law, A
transpose y equals
zero, what does that say, say
in the first row of A transpose?
That says -- the so the first
row of A transpose says minus
y1 minus y3 minus y4 is zero.
Where did that
equation come from?
Let me -- I'll redraw the graph.
Can I redraw the graph here,
so that we -- maybe here,
so that we see again --
there was node one,
node two, node three,
node four was off here.
That was, that was our graph.
We had currents on those.
We had a current y1 going there.
We had a current y --
what were the other,
what are those edge numbers?
y4 here and y3 here.
And then a y2 and a y5.
I'm, I'm just copying what
was on the other board
so it's ea-
convenient to see it.
What is this equation telling
me, this first equation
of Kirchoff's Current Law?
What does that mean
for that graph?
Well, I see y1, y3, and y4 as
the currents leaving node one.
So sure enough, the first
equation refers to node one,
and what does it say?
It says that the
net flow is zero.
That, that equation A transpose
y, Kirchoff's Current Law,
is a balance equation,
a conservation law.
Physicists, be overjoyed,
right, by this stuff.
It, it says that in equals out.
And in this case, the three
arrows are all going out,
so it says y1, y3,
and y4 add to zero.
Let's take the next one.
The second row is y1-y2, and
that's all that's in that row.
And that must have something
to do with node two.
And sure enough, it says y1=y2,
current in equals current out.
The third one, y2 plus
y3 minus y5 equals
zero.
That certainly will be
what's up at the third node.
y2 coming in, y3 coming in,
y5 going out has to balance.
And finally, y4
plus y5 equals zero
says that at this node, y4
plus y5, the total flow,
We don't -- you know, charge
doesn't accumulate at is zero.
the nodes.
It travels around.
OK.
Now give me --
I come back now to the
linear algebra question.
What's a vector y that
solves these equations?
Can I figure out
what the null space
is for this matrix, A transpose,
by looking at the graph?
I'm happy if I don't
have to do elimination.
I can do elimination,
we know how to do,
we know how to find
the null space basis.
We can do elimination
on this matrix,
and we'll get it into a good
reduced row echelon form,
and the special solutions
will pop right out.
But I would like to --
even to do it without that.
Let me just ask you first,
if I did elimination
on that, on that, matrix, what
would the last row become?
What would the last row -- if I
do elimination on that matrix,
the last row of R will
be all zeros, right?
Why?
Because the rank is three.
We only going to
have three pivots.
And the fourth row will be
all zeros when we eliminate.
So elimination will tell us
what, what we spotted earlier,
what's the null space -- all
the, all the information,
what are the dependencies.
We'll find those by elimination,
but here in a real example,
we can find them by thinking.
OK.
Again, my question is,
what is a solution y?
How could current travel
around this network
without collecting any
charge at the nodes?
Tell me a y.
OK.
So a basis for the null
space of A transpose.
How many vectors I looking for?
Two.
It's a two dimensional space.
My basis should have
two vectors in it.
Give me one.
One set of currents.
Suppose, let me start it.
Let me start with y1 as one.
OK.
So one unit of -- one amp
travels on edge one with
the arrow.
OK, then what?
What is y2?
It's one also, right?
And of course what you did was
solve Kirchoff's Current Law
quickly in the second equation.
OK.
Now we've got one amp leaving
node one, coming around to node
three.
What shall we do now?
Well, what shall I take
for y3 in other words?
Oh, I've got a choice, but
why not make it what you said,
negative one.
So I have just sent current,
one amp, around that loop.
What shall y4 and
y5 be in this case?
We could take them to be zero.
This satisfies
Kirchoff's Current Law.
We could check it patiently,
that minus y1 minus y3
gives zero.
We know y1 is y2.
The others, y4 plus
y5 is certainly zero.
Any current around
a loop satisfies --
satisfies the Current Law.
Now you know how
to get another one.
OK.
Take current around this loop.
So now let y3 be one, y5 be
one, and y4 be minus one.
And so, so we have the first
basis vector sent current
around that loop, the
second basis vector
sends current around that
loop.
And I've -- and those
are independent,
and I've got two solutions --
two vectors in the null space
of A transpose, two solutions
to Kirchoff's Current Law.
Of course you would
say what about sending
current around the big loop.
What about that vector?
One for y1, one for y2,
nothing f- on y3, one for y5,
and minus one for y4.
What about that?
Is that, is that in the
null space of A transpose?
Sure.
So why don't we now have a
third vector in the basis?
Because it's not
independent, right?
It's not independent.
This vector is the
sum of those two.
If I send current around
that and around that --
then on this edge y3 it's going
to cancel out and I'll have
altogether current around
the whole, the outside loop.
That's what this
one is, but it's
a combination of those two.
Do you see that I've now, I've
identified the null space of A
transpose --
but more than that, we've
solved Kirchoff's Current Law.
And understood it in
terms of the network.
OK.
So that's the null
space of A transpose.
I guess I -- there's always one
more space to ask you about.
Let's see, I guess I need the
row space of A, the column
space of A transpose.
So what's N, what's
its dimension?
Yup?
What's the dimension
of the row space of A?
If I look at the original
A, it had five rows.
How many were independent?
Oh, I guess I'm asking
you the rank again, right?
And the answer is three, right?
Three independent rows.
When I transpose it, there's
three independent columns.
Are those columns
independent, those three?
The first three columns,
are they the pivot columns
of the matrix?
No.
Those three columns
are not independent.
There's a in fact, this tells
me a relation between them.
There's a vector in
the null space that
says the first column
plus the second column
equals the third column.
They're not independent
because they come from a loop.
So the pivot columns, the
pivot columns of this matrix
will be the first, the second,
not the third, but the fourth.
One, columns one,
two, and four are OK.
Where are they -- those are
the columns of A transpose,
those correspond to edges.
So there's edge one,
there's edge two,
and there's edge four.
So there's a -- that's like --
is a, smaller graph.
If I just look at the part
of the graph that I've, that
I've, thick -- used
with thick edges,
it has the same four nodes.
It only has three edges.
And the, those edges correspond
to the independent guys.
And in the graph there --
those three edges have no loop,
right?
The independent ones are the
ones that don't have a loop.
All the -- dependencies
came from loops.
They were the things in the
null space of A transpose.
If I take three
pivot columns, there
are no dependencies among
them, and they form a graph
without a loop, and I
just want to ask you
what's the name for a
graph without a loop?
So a graph without a loop is
-- has got not very many edges,
right?
I've got four nodes and
it only has three edges,
and if I put another edge
in, I would have a loop.
So it's this graph
with no loops,
and it's the one where the
rows of A are independent.
And what's a graph
called that has no loops?
It's called a tree.
So a tree is the name for
a graph with no loops.
And just to take
one last step here.
Using our formula for dimension.
Using our formula for
dimension, let's look --
once at this formula.
The dimension of the null
space of A transpose is m-r.
OK.
This is the number of loops,
number of independent loops.
m is the number of edges.
And what is r?
What is r for our -- we'll
have to remember way back.
The rank came -- from looking
at the columns of our matrix.
So what's the rank?
Let's just remember.
Rank was -- you remember
there was one --
we had a one dimensional
-- rank was n minus one,
that's what I'm
struggling to say.
Because there were n columns
coming from the n nodes,
so it's minus, the number
of nodes minus one,
because of that C, that
one one one one vector
in the null space.
The columns were
not independent.
There was one dependency,
so we needed n minus one.
This is a great formula.
This is like the
first shall I, --
write it slightly differently?
The number of edges --
let me put things --
have I got it right?
Number of edges is m, the
number -- r- is m-r, OK.
So, so I'm getting --
let me put the number of
nodes on the other side.
So I -- the number of nodes --
I'll move that to
the other side --
minus the number of edges
plus the number of loops is --
I have minus, minus one is one.
The number of nodes
minus the number
of edges plus the
number of loops is one.
These are like zero
dimensional guys.
They're the points on the graph.
The edges are like one
dimensional things,
they're, they connect nodes.
The loops are like two
dimensional things.
They have, like, an area.
And this count works
for every graph.
And it's known as
Euler's Formula.
We see Euler again,
that guy never stopped.
OK.
And can we just check
-- so what I saying?
I'm saying that linear algebra
proves Euler's Formula.
Euler's Formula is this great
topology fact about any graph.
I'll draw, let me
draw another graph,
let me draw a graph with
more edges and loops.
Let me put in lots of --
OK.
I just drew a graph there.
So what are the, what are the
quantities in that formula?
How many nodes have I got?
Looks like five.
How many edges have I got?
One two three four
five six seven.
How many loops have I got?
One two three.
And Euler's right,
I always get one.
That, this formula, is extremely
useful in understanding
the relation of these quantities
-- the number of nodes,
the number of edges,
and the number of loops.
OK.
Just complete this
lecture by completing
this picture, this cycle.
So let me come to the --
so this expresses the
equations of applied math.
This, let me call these
potential differences,
say, E. So E is A x.
That's the equation
for this step.
The currents come from
the potential differences.
y is C E.
The potential -- the currents
satisfy Kirchoff's Current Law.
Those are the equations of --
with no source terms.
Those are the equations of
electrical circuits of many --
those are like the, the
most basic three equations.
Applied math comes
in this structure.
The only thing I haven't
got yet in the picture
is an outside source to
make something happen.
I could add a
current source here,
I could, I could add
external currents
going in and out of nodes.
I could add batteries
in the edges.
Those are two ways.
If I add batteries in the edges,
they, they come into here.
Let me add current sources.
If I add current sources,
those come in here.
So there's a, there's
where current sources go,
because the F is a like a
current coming from outside.
So we have our edges,
we have our graph,
and then I send one amp into
this node and out of this node
-- and that gives
me, a right-hand side
in Kirchoff's Current Law.
And can I -- to
complete the lecture,
I'm just going to put these
three equations together.
So I start with x, my unknown.
I multiply by A.
That gives me the
potential differences.
That was our matrix A that
the whole thing started with.
I multiply by C.
Those are the physical
constants in Ohm's Law.
Now I have y.
I multiply y by A
transpose, and now I have F.
So there is the whole thing.
There's the basic
equation of applied math.
Coming from these three steps,
in which the last step is
this balance equation.
There's always a balance
equation to look for.
These are the --
when I say the most basic
equations of applied
mathematics --
I should say, in equilibrium.
Time isn't in this problem.
I'm not -- and Newton's
Law isn't acting here.
I'm, I'm looking at the --
equations when everything has
settled down, how do
the currents distribute
in the network.
And of course there are
big codes to solve the --
this is the basic problem
of numerical linear algebra
for systems of equations,
because that's how they come.
And my final question.
What can you tell me about
this matrix A transpose C A?
Or even A transpose A?
I'll just close
with that question.
What do you know about
the matrix A transpose A?
It is always symmetric, right.
OK, thank.
So I'll see you Wednesday for a
full review of these chapters,
and Friday you get to tell me.
Thanks.